[Music]
one thing we don't talk about is that
it's sort of hard to talk about this our
minds have these kinds of backdoors
there's just there's kind of if you're a
human if you wake up and you open your
eyes there is a certain set of
dimensions to your experience that can
be manipulated when I was a kid I was a
magician and you learn all about these
limits you know that short-term memory
is about this long and there's different
reaction times and if you ask people
certain questions in certain ways you
can control the answer and this is just
the structure of being human to be human
means that you are persuadable in every
single moment I mean the thing about
magic as an example is that magic works
on everybody sleight of hand right it
doesn't matter what language you speak
it doesn't matter how intelligent you
are it's not about what someone knows
it's about how your mind actually works
so knowing this it turns out that
there's this whole playbook of
persuasive techniques that actually I
learned when I was at the Stanford
persuasive technology lab and that most
people in Silicon Valley in the tech
industry learned as ways of getting your
attention so one example is we are all
vulnerable to social approval we really
care what other people think of us so
for example you know when you upload a
new photo a new profile photo of
yourself on Facebook that's a moment
where our mind is very vulnerable to
knowing what other people think of my
new profile photo and so when we get new
likes on our profile photo Facebook
knowing this could actually message me
and say oh you have new likes on your
profile photo and we it knows it will be
vulnerable to that moment because we all
really care about when we're tagged in a
photo or when we have a new profile
photo and the thing is that they control
the dial the technology companies
control the dial for when and how long
your profile photo shows up on other
people's newsfeeds
so they can orchestrate it so that other
people more often end up liking your
profile photo over a delayed period of
time for example so that you end up
having to more frequently come back and
see what the new likes are right and the
problem is that they don't do
because they're evil they do it because
again they're in this race for our
attention and we should also ask is that
necessarily such a bad thing
if they're orchestrating it so that
other people like my my photo I mean I
might feel good to me but so we have to
have a new conversation about as these
technology companies use these
techniques these vulnerabilities in our
minds when is that actually aligned and
good for us when is that ethical when is
that honest when is that fair and when
is that dishonest and unfair because
they're actually manipulating our minds
in a way that doesn't add up to our
spending our time well on the screen
well so another vulnerability in our
mind is something called a variable
schedule reward and that's like a slot
machine in Las Vegas it turns out that
slot machines make more money in the
United States then baseball movies and
theme parks combined people become
addicted to slot machines I think it's 2
to 3 times faster than any other kind of
gambling in a casino so it's insane and
why is that because it's very simple you
just pull a lever and sometimes you get
a reward you know and sometimes you
don't and the more random it is and the
more variable it is the more addictive
it becomes and the thing is that that
turns our phone into a slot machine
because every time we check our phone
were playing the slot machine to see
what did I get
right every time that we check our email
we're playing the slot machine to see
what did I get did I get invited to an
interview a big thing or did I just get
another newsletter right or if you're on
a dating site like tinder and when
you're swiping each swipe is you're
playing the slot machine to see did I
get a match I'm playing the slot machine
to see that I going to match and the
problem is that this dynamic these
variable schedule rewards or the slot
machine mechanic is so powerful that
it's the best thing at addicting people
and putting you in the zone one of the
original designers of the Facebook
newsfeed told me that the thing that
made the newsfeed work at the very very
very beginning back in 2006 was in part
a hardware innovation and I looked at
her and I said what
you mean and she said it was actually
the the scroll wheel on a mouse because
with the scroll wheel on a mouse your
hand never had to leave its resting
position you just scroll to see the next
thing and the because before that you
had to click on the down button or drag
move your mouse and drag the arrow down
and scroll the page that way when you
don't you can take your two fingers on a
trackpad and do this or you can just
scroll on a scroll wheel it just means
your hand never has to leave its resting
position and it's more like a slot
machine you can just keep swiping and
playing just like in Vegas whether it's
the button right there they actually
changed it in fact it used to be a lever
and now it's just a button in Vegas
because it sounds it's easier just to
get people to to see if they get a match
this way so how much on our phones when
we use our technology Instagram is like
a slot machine what's going to come next
on the feeds you know snapchat is a slot
machine each time you see the red
notifications and you don't know what's
behind it you're playing with slot
machine when you click on it to see what
did I get right and so it sprinkled all
throughout these products because it's a
very compelling way of getting people's
attention
[Music]